okay this is very interesting this is a
headline from a news article you ready
the bacteria Conan super resistant to
radiation could survive million years on
Mars
it's nicknamed Conan it's named Conan
why oh yeah why do they need well I
guess it's actually Conan Conan the
bacteria but I thought that that might
be relevant well
um I think I in I mean I'm very
resilient
um in my career yeah many times there's
been attempts to destroy me and I come
back
um like a persistent
bacteria so I see it I see it yeah I'm
proud to be linked to
a rare bacteria
that can exist in the harshest harshest
climates you are I wouldn't want there's
a lot of things to be named after me I
wouldn't want bacteria to be one of them
what would you like to be named after
you a building
why not why don't we name this building
the Sonam of cesian
Hall I don't I don't think we can
because I really think of this as Erica
Brown's oh yeah that's more relevant
Erica takes care of his place and runs
it and she's you know uh this is Erica's
house I agree so
um I say can I have a wing no okay and
it's just Wing it's not winga there's no
hard G why do you always do that you
waste everybody's time every single time
you have can I have a wing okay if
there's a g at the end of the word I
don't know why why do you think you're
right we're not right well I think Matt
will tell you come on don't bring Madden
Matt be honest
who's just like me no offense but you
guys are like yeah we're yeah we're my
family's been here forever so we know an
Englishman excuse me I wasn't gonna
defend you and then you threw me under
the white man's bus yeah that's wrong
well first of all gorley you've been in
the country the longest personally well
no I mean your family my family yeah I
think your people they they you look
like guys that were working on a podcast
on the Mayflower came over that's
absolutely right and um there's a
hundred percent
well we left the great podcast Famine of
Ireland and then had to come over
people were eating microphones and
they're like we gotta get out of here
um
yeah I would always assume that that you
uh what year did your family come over
well I want to say it was a late 1860s
1870s and um but but as we've said many
times my people made the Dreadful
mistake of um not diversifying the line
right uh and so um like royalty like
royalty I am much like royalty and that
I am horribly inbred uh Irish Trash
anywho
um my children have been saved because
my lovely wife uh embodies many
different genetic strains and so my
children have surpassed me they have
powers that I could only dream of
they're only half inbred
that's a nice way to say did you say
that about my children yeah what you
said I did yeah actually I'm thinking
about it and it's just true it is no
it's just true okay I was gonna get mad
and then I was like oh this is true
um but uh but yeah so no this is not in
me giving you a hard time because you
you know came to this country as a child
that's not I didn't I
was born here we've been through this no
I was born here you can't convince me
that I was not born in this country
say it often because I was born here
born where exactly Montebello Montebello
is not in the United States
I grew up in two cities away from
Monticello yeah yeah just because you
don't you like I think it's in
Montebello is an island in international
waters oh my God I'm pretty sure anyway
the point is anyways just name a wing
after me I winga I don't care maybe get
a winga at the Montebello Town Center oh
I'll take it yes and you should is there
anything honoring you in in Montebello
no you should be you were a celebrity
you were a legitimate celebrity uh well
I'm not but you are you have a you have
a book that was a New York Times
bestseller right
um it's out right now and uh you I bring
up your name in front of any crowd you
get big cheers that's nice you are known
you are a known person and who else who
are you competing with whatever
celebrities are there in Montebello you
know what I don't know Eduardo Eduardo
is from Montebello for Montebello yeah I
know anybody from
I'm gonna just put this out there yeah I
do think Sona should have some kind of
recognition by Montebello I agree I
don't know if it's a park bench
um
I'll take a park I think you should be
Grand Marshal in the Montebello
Christmas parade yes is that a Christmas
party I don't know there should be we'll
make a parade and I'll be the Grand
Marshal I don't know I think that people
always want me to do things because they
think you'll do them with me yeah but
that's called the old bait and switch
yeah I know but you should be honored by
Montebello because you are what uh oh so
I just pulled up on Google Montebello
celebrities and on the short list of
like eight people sona's name is
thank you
hey
wow what number is it and above or below
who else it's uh three after sir Han
Sirhan
Robert Kennedy's assassin so you should
feel pretty good she's number seven and
who else is on there anyone we'd know uh
Gina Rodriguez I think she's an actress
yep actor yeah uh divorce I don't know
that I know just say some names Tim
Lankford nope Chelsea Rendon nope
actress Michelle Bauer you're bigger
than all these people what Michael
Trevino also an actor and Deborah
Foreman no
I bet if I looked up Brookline
Massachusetts notable people from
Brookline Massachusetts don't say
Eduardo but it would probably not
include me because it's because I
there's so many famous people John F
Kennedy John F Kennedy you guys both had
presidents from your cities that's right
that's very cool and I'm you know what I
mean and so would say things like John F
Kennedy number one number two Wilson
fetterman number three
Alicia Cornwallis
number four no can we see what number
you are on the list number two famous
Brooklyn I Googled it Conan's number two
I knew it I knew it nice she was number
one John FK he always wins what about
Alicia what did he ever do oh yeah but
your country can't go for you yeah
my God it's getting worse sorry I have
to I have to keep making it a stranger
and strange yeah
um Gotti always beats me out he should
he always will yeah you need a library
you need to do a library there there
needs to be a Conan O'Brien live this is
a bad idea this is a great idea how
about this in Montebello I bet I could
get a Conan O'Brien Library if they put
the son of obsession bench out front
I'll take a bench if but you get a you
want a library yeah okay it's there's
more fun buildings
like more fun than a library Corley what
do you make of that blasphemy
I don't want to take sides okay don't
you want to school wouldn't a school be
cool if it's named after you I go to
O'Brien High yeah we're uh how about
that yeah Conan O'Brien school where all
the kids are bullied
there are no bullies only kids who are
bullied they're going to be huge bullies
bring people in to bully them but they
aren't actually part of the curriculum
but they may leave as bullies they get
trained into being bullied
I was taught by my older brothers who
bullied me not Luke Neil definitely
um but then you passed it on probably to
like Kade and Justin and really Justin I
went hard after Justin that's not nice
it's not nice but I tried to make it it
was done to you and you did it to your
younger brother that's not cool I don't
know O'Brien High yeah no O'Brien hi
only bullied kids no bullies oh God I
just don't know why bust the bullies in
I don't think they bust them in because
they're there it's just what the Conan
O'Brien school is all the kids wear
pants that don't fit they're not long
enough
where did they get the bullies from is
that another school or like yes the
bullies are professional bullies that
are shipped in they're paid the same way
that the teachers are paid they have a
union wow they're brought in they bully
and uh hey what do you think you're
going bang hey what's stuffing in omaka
hey guys it's uh three o'clock all right
time to check out let's go I'm getting
their cars and driving why would anyone
go there anyway look for it soon uh
Conan O'Brien uh elementary school and
you can find it because the uh Sonoma
Obsession uh three-legged bench oh I
don't even that four no that's expensive
and anytime you try and sit it it dumps
you it falls over and dumps you out of
the lawn also there's also bacteria on
Mars named cone oh yeah yeah well hey
your own okay Roy we really we really
had fun with that story